[cymbals softly ringing]
Narrator: Ah, the northern lights.
Beautiful to see...and hear?
[wind chimes gently ringing]
The thing is,
the northern lights don't
actually make a sound.
Yet when you watch this clip,
you don't think twice about it.
In fact, if you start to
really look, and listen,
closely to everything from "Planet Earth"
to "Our Planet," you'll notice sounds
that would either be
impossible to capture...
[Slinky shaking]
or ones that are straight-up made up.
[leather squishing]
Nature documentaries are
full of unnatural sounds,
and they're created in postproduction
by someone like Richard Hinton,
whose job as a nature doc Foley artist
is a study in the subtle
art of exaggeration.
So, why even create
sounds for nature docs?
[lips smacking]
Well, shooting in the wild
makes it almost impossible
to capture real sound.
Take this aerial shot of a
dolphin pod in "Our Planet."
It was filmed high up
in the air by a drone,
so while the dolphins are
splashing up and down,
all the camera picks up are loud blades.
Nature docs also frequently
utilize macro lenses,
meaning they might actually
be shooting a subject matter
that's across a valley,
or they'll capture
objects normally too small
to have a registered noise to it.
That means that sometimes
Richard and his team at Films at 59
will actually have to fake
sounds to give life to it.
Richard Hinton: You can
fill a television screen
with a shot of a spider
walking across a web,
and there's no sound there, obviously,
and that can feel a bit strange,
or there's a hole in the story.
[magnetic tape rustling]
Narrator: For "The Hunt,"
he needed to get the sound
of a spider shooting a web.
Hinton: I really like
doing stuff like this,
because I get carte blanche
to be a little creative.
Because there's no
perceivable sound in nature,
it means I can kind of make something up.
Narrator: But while he
can make something up,
he still needs to match the
sound he's watching on screen.
For the web, he needed
something really stretchy,
so he grabbed a Slinky
and stretched it out
as far as possible.
[Slinky rattling]
Hinton: You get that
wonderful cable under tension.
Narrator: Now, it sounded good
when he just stretched it out
between his hands, like you see here,
but because the camera was so close,
he needed a really close sound.
So he applied proximity effect,
where the Foley artist will make a sound
as close to the mic as possible.
It's actually a risky move.
Hinton: The microphone is
almost feeding back on itself
because you're too close to the mic
or you're overloading the mic.
Narrator: But he found the winning noise
only by shoving the Slinky
right on top of the mic.
Hinton: That proximity just
pulls you in really tight
to the action and what's
going on on the screen,
and it just makes it sound more unworldly.
Narrator: He didn't
just need the web blast.
He also had to capture a
spider's tiny footsteps,
yet another thing in nature
that normally wouldn't have a sound,
at least that humans could hear.
He needed something more delicate
than most animal footsteps.
He started playing with a
bunch of magnetic audio tape,
a classic Foley technique that can cover
many types of sounds.
Hinton: You could use this,
but it sounds too clumpy.
It's not delicate enough.
It's not precise enough.
If I wrap it around the reel,
I can use the reel as a sounding board.
[magnetic tape rustling]
And you can get individual footsteps.
Narrator: Close-ups also mean he will need
to exaggerate parts of a larger animal
you wouldn't normally hear a sound from.
For example, when working
on Disney's "Bears,"
Richard needed to capture the sound
of a bear opening its eye and blinking.
Because a bear is covered in fur,
he first rubbed a piece of fur
to capture the lid opening.
[fur rustling]
But Richard actually needed
to create two sounds,
as he observed that moisture forms
when one opens their eyes.
For a wetter sound, he
relied on his own mouth.
[mouth salivating]
It's when these two
sounds are mixed together
that you really hear the lid opening.
[fur rustling]
[mouth salivating]
The up-close-and-personal
presentation of nature docs
is what brings Richard to create
some of the most innovative noises.
Thanks to amazing HD cameras,
time-lapse technology has changed
what a nature doc can capture,
and we can now witness the
entire cycle of a plant growing.
Hinton: The beauty, from my
point of view as a Foley artist,
because it is such a stylized shot,
I don't have to think too carefully
about being true to nature.
It gives me a certain
level of creative freedom.
Narrator: Like with the spider web,
Richard needed a stretchy sound
for this shot from "Planet Earth II,"
where mushrooms and other
fungi spring from the ground.
But he wanted a sound more
organic than a Slinky.
He first went for a mushy
effect with a wet newspaper,
but he needed more control.
[newspaper squishing]
Through this trial and error,
he found leather strips and scuba gear
were the only things both
stretchy and controllable enough.
[strips stretching]
To add a little sweetener,
Richard played around
with a wet leather shammy.
[shammy squishing]
Hinton: And this is a
particularly useful lad too
if you're showing the decay of the fungus
as well as the growth,
because usually they kind
of melt into a sticky,
kind of wet, moist,
oozy kind of substance.
[shammy squishing]
[strips stretching]
Narrator: Now, there are
certain things in nature docs
that you wouldn't hear even
if you got up close to it,
because they are simply
a visual phenomenon,
like the northern lights
we mentioned earlier.
[cymbals softly ringing]
For some animal movements
there is a real sound,
but it's not very pleasant to listen to,
so he needs to create something better,
like he did for these underwater
shots in "Our Planet."
Hinton: You don't really
hear much sound underwater.
Although sound travels very well,
it's very [hisses and crackles].
It would become very tiresome to listen to
after about two minutes.
Your ears would get really tired,
and you'd probably turn it off.
So we embellish a little bit.
Narrator: Unsurprisingly,
he uses real water,
but it's how his hands
interact with the water
that makes the difference.
Hinton: The smaller the animal,
the more delicate you can be.
Narrator: When it gets
to more medium-size fish,
like this large shoal of
mackerel in "Our Planet,"
he'll also dump that clump of
magnetic tape into the tank
for an extra layer of sound.
[water splashing]
Hinton: What you can do is
you can focus on the moving shoal
and really focus on those tight turns
and those sharp movements.
[water splashing]
Narrator: If there's more than
one type of aquatic animal
in the shot, Richard will differentiate
by doing one take with the
magnetic tape and one without.
[water splashing]
For something larger, like
a whale, seen in this shot,
he'll both make his movements larger
and go deeper into the water.
[water intensely splashing]
There is always extra editing that goes on
after Richard is done recording.
Richard will later apply an EQ,
which filters out harsher
frequency and adds depth,
making it at least feel like
it is really recorded under the ocean.
Listen to this before...
[water crisply splashing]
and after.
[muffled water splashing]
Lava makes a surprisingly soft sound,
and when Richard had to exaggerate it
for this scene in "Planet Earth II,"
he wanted it to have more impact.
Hinton: You kind of hear the interaction
of what it's setting fire to
more than the sound of the lava creeping.
Narrator: Now, just the fire crackling
doesn't give much of a
sense of the massive scale
of a lava flow.
He needed a low-end rumble.
He uses smaller rocks when making glaciers
to capture the debris
but went for a much larger one here.
Hinton: For this, I put some gloves on
because there's a real danger
of losing a fingernail.
[boulder rumbling]
It's a very bass-y sound.
Narrator: While Richard
has a lot of freedom
on nature shows and movies,
there's one area he really
can't embellish or exaggerate.
Hinton: There's a lot of science around
animal vocalizations these days.
There's a whole range of alarm calls
and distress calls and greeting calls,
so we rely very heavily on
accurate library recordings
to make sure that we're
getting it correct.
Narrator: But Richard will be brought in
for the vocals you might not think about,
such as eating, breathing, or panting.
For "Our Planet,"
Richard was asked to make
a very specific lip-smacking
sound from an orangutan,
as the actual footage
contained crew members
talking in the background.
[lips smacking]
Hinton: And it gets quite painful
if you're doing that for five minutes,
but, you know, Foley is a contact sport,
and we suffer for our art.
[water bubbling]